this video is made possible by
Squarespace whether you need a domain
website or online store make it with
Squarespace check out Squarespace comm
for a free trial you'll also find a link
in the description below
Jill DeRay was a knight he became the
richest man in all of France he became
famous after battling alongside Joan of
Arc in the name of God and he was well
loved by the French people no one could
have imagined that just a few years
later he would be sentenced to death for
summoning a demon and murdering over a
hundred children for hundreds of years
he was considered to be one of the first
serial killers in recorded history
however some modern-day historians
believe that he was framed and they are
trying to exonerate him so did he really
kill innocent children as part of a
satanic sacrifice or is he one of the
most misunderstood figures in all of
history
[Music]
Gilder a was born in his family castle
the Sham toss Salewa in 1405 when he was
a child
Gilda Ray's parents they passed away and
he was raised by his grandfather Jean to
crawl Gilda ray was born during the
Hundred Years War which was a conflict
between the noble families of England
and France
it began in 1337 and ended in 1453
meaning that the war went on for 116
years multiple generations grew up in
non-stop warfare kidnapping death and
torture just became a part of normal
life considering how dangerous it was at
that time it became mandatory for all
men in noble families to be trained in
combat and warfare at 16 years old Jill
de ray rescued the Duke of Brittany who
had been kidnapped and taken prisoner as
a reward for saving the Duke their king
awarded Gilder a land grants that
allowed him to acquire massive
properties for free since he was 12
years old
Gil's grandfather Jean was already
trying to arrange marriage for the boy
his first attempt was with a young
heiress who was only four years old
after trying and failing to arrange
marriage for his grandson a few times
jaunt across was able to broker an
agreement with the noble families in
Brittany since Jill saved their Dukes
life when he was in his early 20s Gilda
Rey married Catherine de thoux la
duchess of Brittany she was the heiress
to one of the biggest fortunes in all of
France back then women could not own or
handle money so estates were controlled
by fathers and husbands so as to the
heir of one of the biggest fortunes in
France from the DeRay family marrying
Catherine du soir made them one of the
richest couples in the entire country
[Music]
nearly everyone has heard the story of
Joan of Arc but it's important to remind
you of her tale because her fate shows
so many parallels to Hilda ray the
French city of alia had been surrounded
and captured by the English Joan of Arc
was just a 17 year old peasant girl when
she appeared before King Charles the
seventh and requested to use his army to
defeat the English and free only oh it's
hard to imagine how such a young woman
without any noble status could have had
an audience with the king let alone get
him to agree to hand over an army but
apparently she was very convincing Joan
claimed that Michael the Archangel
appeared to her in a vision and that God
was on her side she also claimed that
she could miraculously heal her wounds
she demonstrated before the court that
even the deepest wounds would heal with
the power of God she claimed that he was
helping her attain supernatural powers
in order to become invincible some
documents actually claim that the king
was actually terrified of Joan and that
he was practically forced to say yes
shoulder a was 25 years old at the time
he became the marshal of the army and
Joan of Arc's right-hand man in just
nine days the two of them led the army
to victory for France and they became
national heroes and holy figures in
society the fact that they fought in the
name of God and the Archangel Michael
was enough to reinvigorate French
citizens Catholic faith as you might
imagine it was extremely humiliating for
the English to know that they were
defeated by a teenage girl when she was
just 19 years old Joan of Arc was
captured by the burgh Indian party who
were a group of French noblemen spying
for the English she was taken to court
in England and in 1431 she was burned at
the stake for witchcraft a memory lived
on in the hearts of the French people
and she was canonized as a saint by the
Catholic Church
[Music]
the Burgundian party managed to kill a
peasant girl like Joan of Arc but it was
far more difficult to capture a
well-protected noble person like Jill
DeRay he became the marshal of France
and he was even more rich and powerful
than he was before
because he also received awards for
winning the siege of or neon he was also
able to strike business deals with other
nobles who wanted to work with him his
court grew to be even more luxurious
than the King of France and the wealthy
leaders of the Catholic Church he
decided to retire from fighting at this
point he was still very young and had
all the money in the world to do
essentially whatever he wanted with just
like today when people get a windfall of
money at a very early age they sometimes
make some stupid decisions on how to
spend it sports cars and designer
watches hadn't been invented yet but he
did invest in several different estates
since this was investing in real estate
asst family found these kinds of
purchases to be acceptable but it
started to get a little crazy when jill
DeRay began producing plays he spent a
small fortune on theatrical reenactments
of his battles during the Hundred Years
War today producing multi-million dollar
Broadway plays and movies are completely
normal that mag then who was completely
unheard of his play had over 150
speaking roles and over 500 extras who
acted as soldiers in the battle 600
different costumes were commissioned for
the performance and tailors around all
Aeon while working around the clock to
make them he also gave her staff and
even the audience an unlimited buffet of
free food which pretty much guaranteed
that everyone in town would show up to
the formants in his own way he was
actually creating jobs and making people
happy by entertaining and feeding the
peasant class but from the perspective
of his family this was horrifying his
in-laws in Brittany spent multiple
generations saving and investing so that
they had a family legacy and it was
sickening to them that this young man
was practically burning cash in a
garbage fire but of course it was Jill
to raise money and he had every right to
spend it however he wanted Jill doraid
began paying for his own personal chapel
on his estate
this might seem strange but it wasn't
actually that uncommon for members of
the European nobility to have their own
church back in the day this way he could
still attend Mass
and do it from the comfort of his own
home it was called Chapel of the Holy
Innocents named after a verse in the
book of Matthew in this verse King Herod
orders a mass killing of all children
and two years old to prevent a prophecy
from coming true that a child would grow
up to overthrow him from a modern
perspective it seems rather creepy that
schilder a would want a church named
after a story about the murder of
thousands of children but some
historians say that it's exactly the
opposite in the 1400s the story actually
became popular among the French Catholic
community people were making a
comparison to the tragedy of these dying
children in the Bible to the Hundred
Years War because there were entire
generations of people who grew up
without knowing a time of peace it was
finally becoming in vogue to be a
pacifist by naming his personal church
the Chapel of the Holy Innocents he was
actually making a political statement
that he wanted the Hundred Years War to
be over
considering that many of the noble
families profited from constant warfare
and capturing territories this was even
more reason for his in-laws to be angry
with him the Duke of Brittany appears
before the Pope claiming that Jill DeRay
had an addiction to spending money he
requested that the Pope would deny his
application to have the Chapel of the
innocence accepted as an official part
of the Catholic Diocese the Duke hopes
that a rejection would be enough to stop
shield array from completing the chapel
but he went ahead and built it anyway
even though his church did not have a
real Catholic priest there to say Mass
Hilda Rae didn't let that stop him yet
Taylor's custom mega lavish and colorful
costumes for him to wear and he
officiated Mass himself this was
considered to be extremely blasphemous
and he was making a very public
statement that he knew that he had just
as much power as the king and the
Catholic Church and there was pretty
much nothing they could do to stop him
his family met with the King asking for
a royal decree to stop anyone from
entering into a contract with shield
array they claimed they were afraid he
would spend all of his money and that
there would be nothing left in his
estate the King agreed to allow the Duke
of Brittany to take control over
Hilary's estate the Duke of Brittany
began making financial decisions on his
behalf and he completely cut off shield
array from all of his money after
looking over his financial records the
Duke told Jill DeRay that he had spent
everything
he owns and that he was now in debt so
he therefore began selling his
properties one by one later Jill DeRay
learns that one of his favorite castles
that the Duke had apparently sold was
actually being guarded by a Catholic
clergyman named Jean Lafleur
and that no one was actually living
there at all he was incredibly angry
about this he wasn't going to stand for
the Duke trying to make him both
penniless and homeless he wanted to go
back inside so he beat and kidnapped
Jean Lafleur
in order to get the new keys to the
castle kidnapping a clergyman was a very
serious crime he did eventually let the
man go but in the eyes of the noble
community
it was extremely shocking that schulder
a would do such a thing
it was becoming clear to both the king
and the Pope that Joel DeRay was not
going to go down without a fight
he was so powerful he could get away
with just about anything and stay out of
jail the French people loved him for
being a hero and for his generosity to
the peasant classes if he wanted to he
even had the ability to raise his own
army this was a very scary thing for the
powers that be and they needed to stop
it now just before we get into the
darker part of this story where he
apparently starts killing people I do
want to tell you about today's sponsor
and I know that having the sponsor in
the middle of the video is not the most
awesome thing that these videos are very
long and given the length that we put
out I really hope you do appreciate the
need to put the sponsorships in the
middle but I will keep it super brief
Squarespace allows you to create a
powerful online presence whether that's
for a personal site a business or
something else entirely
it all starts on Squarespace with a
beautiful template that comes with the
requisite cool names like Pursuit and
rice you can either start from scratch
or easily move over an existing domain
making everything super easy to manage
and once you're through the super easy
customization process there's no updates
no patches none of that stuff you have
to deal with when you're making a
website on another platform you know all
that super frustrating stuff look if
you're looking to start a business
pursue a dream whatever just do it with
Squarespace head to squarespace.com for
a free trial and when you're ready to go
launch go to Squarespace calm /pi
graphics - save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain do keep
in mind going through that link helps us
keep making these videos all right let's
talk about some killing
[Music]
Zelda Reyes family began circulating
rumors that he had gone mad and that he
was experimenting with alchemy even if
this was true alchemy was very
misunderstood this wasn't a form of
witchcraft it was actually a very early
form of chemistry years later other
monarchs like Queen Elizabeth the first
would hire alchemists as well but
according to this rumor he was taking
those alchemists practices one step too
far
taking them into the occult and that it
actually sold his soul to the devil he
partnered with an Italian man named
Francois Pilate he was rumored to also
be an alchemist some even say that the
two men were in a forbidden romantic
relationship and that they both
attempted to summon a demon named Baron
they said that Baron would be able to
make gold appear out of thin air after
trying three times and failing Francois
pro-nazi apparently told Jill DeRay that
if they wanted to make the spell work
they would need to be human sacrifice as
the story goes Zelda Ray lured children
to his castle with the goal of killing
them in a ritualistic sacrifice in the
15th century children would walk the
streets alone and go missing all the
time we now know that young kids should
never walk at City Street unsupervised
but at that time parents wanted someone
else to blame when their child
disappeared back then it was impossible
for people to fathom that even Catholic
priests were actually pedophiles who
were responsible for many of the
disappearances for the citizens of a
deeply religious Catholic nation it was
actually easier for people to believe
that one devil worshipping serial
killing Alchemist was responsible for
the deaths of all the missing children
in France
according to the stories elder a would
bring in young boys to the castle with
the promises of making them his page or
his Squire honored to have their son
work with one of the most famous Knights
in the country and they wouldn't think
twice about letting their son leave with
a stranger on a horse the boy however
had never come back the court claimed
that he would decapitate the children
collect their heads on stakes and ask
his houseguests which one they thought
was the most beautiful he grew tired of
collecting heads and began sacrificing
these children on a satanic altar
allowing the rotting bodies to pile up
and sometimes burning the corpses
the fireplace after he was accused of
worshipping Satan and killing children
Zelda Rae and all his servants denied
the claims his friends also came forward
and testified on his behalf saying that
this was all a lion that they never saw
anything at all like that
in his castle but their testimonies they
were left out of the trial after
enduring physical torture they finally
signed confessions to a story that had
been written about their crimes they
arms these signed confessions there was
never any physical proof that any of
this actually ever happens in 1440 Zelda
Rae was convicted of witchcraft and
murder he was executed on October the
16th of that year the Duke of Brittany
gains control over all of his money and
land and divided it among his family the
king even gave him permission to take
possession of any former lands that had
been sold to pay for Joel to raise debts
the Catholic Church also got a huge
chunk of money from this donation
some say that Zelda Ray's body was
burned after hanging which was the
procedure for anyone accused of
witchcraft
however the Gutenberg Project which
studies various witchcraft cases
throughout history says that they found
evidence that he was actually given a
Christian burial this was kept a secret
because it would prove that the clergy
completely made up the accusations of
witchcraft and devil worship this story
was so shocking and salacious among the
French people it was hard to believe
that anyone could make up such a story
about anyone - then it felt like they
were duped into trusting a wolf in
sheep's clothing the story was told over
and over again and it just became a part
of French folklore the story sends the
message that with enough money and
enough power the aristocracy can get
away with anything and that the common
people must seek justice for inequality
hanging zelda ray became like a victory
for the people and the peasant classes
and many people still believe to this
very day that the story they've been
told is the truth
[Music]
while it's true that Jill DeRay
confessed to the murders it was only
after torturing him and threatening to
excommunicate him from France they never
discovered any bodies of children on his
property even if they were burned that
would still be bone fragments somewhere
there all of the evidence it was
circumstantial and it would never hold
up in a court of law today in 1992 the
New York Times reported about the
possibility of reopening the case
of Zelda Rae many French historians got
very defensive about the case saying
that he was truly an awful serial killer
and that it's not possible that anyone
would be falsely accused of something so
horrific for years a woman named Margot
KGB collected nearly every book that had
been published with information about
Zelda Rae she went as far as to
translate the original trial documents
from Latin and read all of the
biographies in both French and English
she even discovered that the transcripts
were also altered after the trial was
over changing Jill de Rais testimony to
sound even more over-the-top adding even
more gruesome details to his supposed
confession about slaughtering children
Jimmy wrote her own biography on Zelda
Rae and held a public retrial on his
behalf she proved that if the same trial
happened today there would never be
enough evidence to convict him of murder
for some this was enough to officially
exonerate him for others they will never
be able to let go of the idea that Jill
DeRay was one of the worst serial
killers who ever lived so I hope you
found their video interesting if you did
please do give us a thumbs up below and
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos twice a week also as I mentioned
do check out our sponsor Squarespace
you'll find a link to them in the
description below and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]